revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 y me acompaña en el estudio
rosa pérez de rosa bienvenida ya estamos
a 10 finalizamos una semana más aquí en
directo américa idiomas abrir esta
revista de prensa con un artículo del
medio fox.com que informa la sequía el
río colorado es tan fuerte que aparecía
que se ve mejor desde el espacio se
aprecia el espacio es un artículo de
maíz y funk buenos días raúl exactamente
se habla de la peor sequía en 1200 años
y es que el sistema del río colorado
está al 34 por ciento de su capacidad lo
que ya ha provocado cortes de agua en
los estados de arizona nevada y nuevo
méxico y queríamos a destacar como
argumento la necesidad de implementar
estas restricciones tania trujillo quien
es subsecretaria de agua y ciencia del
departamento de interior ella dijo que
se debe reducir el uso de agua para
evitar un colapso catastrófico del
sistema del río colorado y un futuro de
incertidumbre y conflicto y lo que es
destacable desde declaraciones a nuestro
parecer es que se hable de un futuro
catastrófico de esta posibilidad en
lugar de una realidad que ya estamos
viviendo en el presente así es rosa y
precisamente la nasa monitorea desde
hace años estas vías fluviales y
constata cómo se está secando la región
exactamente se habla de una sequía
dentro de otra sequía de la sequía de
los últimos dos años desde 2020 hasta
ahora 2022 dentro de la sequía de las
últimas dos décadas no desde principios
de los años 2000 influenciadas por el
cambio climático y como decíamos es tal
esta reducción del caudal del sistema
del río colorado que se aprecia desde el
espacio particularmente desde las
imágenes satelitales satelitales
registradas por la nasa de hecho se
refleja muy bien esta reducción del
volumen de agua si nos fijamos en las
imágenes del lago mead y del lago power
que estamos viendo si van aquí detrás y
no hay agua vemos como como se mueven de
hecho y como la primera imagen donde hay
más agua responde en el caso del lago
mit este de acá al año 2000 mientras que
donde hay menos agua es ya la situación
de este 2022 que este lago el lago mit
que se encuentra entre nevada y arizona
se encuentra un 27 por ciento de su
capacidad mientras que por otro lago por
otro lado el lago powell que se
encuentra entre yuta y arizona se
encuentra el 26 por ciento de su
capacidad y la imagen donde vemos que
tiene más agua es de 1999 y la que tiene
menos desde el pasado 2021 no una
diferencia pues muy evidente en tan sólo
esos 20 años y el papel es el que más
pues evidencia nuestra crisis climática
que estamos enfrentando la escasez de
agua de más efectivamente y también
vemos muy claramente lo que decíamos la
sequía dentro de la sequía porque si nos
fijamos en el lago sacha y en el lago
oroville vemos la reducción del volumen
de agua en tan solo los últimos dos años
no estamos viendo aquí lo que se ilumina
en blanco en estas imágenes
la diferencia del caudal de estos
halagos como como se ha reducido como
bien decíamos en los últimos dos años
y bien para terminar un poco con este
artículo nos insisten en que como más
aumente la temperatura global pues más
demanda de agua va a haber tanto para
consumo como para agricultura o para
generar electricidad y que todo esto
está aumentando irreversiblemente la
tensión en política por la distribución
de los recursos y además a las sequías
rosas están entre los 10 retos
climáticos que afronta la región de
latinoamérica en nuestra región tal y
como lo explica un artículo de américa
futuro en la sección de el país
exactamente y en este artículo flor
antonia singer habló con los autores del
último informe de la organización
meteorológica mundial en que señalan
cuáles son las zonas más afectadas de la
región de américa latina y el caribe y
también cuáles son los principales retos
climáticos que afronta esta región que
ya de por sí está caracterizada por una
importante variabilidad climática pero
que se acentúa por el calentamiento
global precisamente el peruano josé
antonio marengo autor de este informe
dice que se habla de un futuro de
extremos pero ya está sucediendo lo que
comentábamos respecto a la sequía del
río colorado bien para mencionarlos
rápidamente estos 10 retos hablamos de
los fenómenos de la niña el niño y los
extremos no aunque hay demasiada a veces
hay demasiada lluvia a veces demasiada
poca no dice el artículo cada vez llueve
menos pero cuando hay eventos de precio
y precipitación son extremos con las
consecuencias que tiene esto tanto para
la agricultura como también para muchas
residencias muchas construcciones
precarias en el continente por otro lado
también hablamos del aumento de la
temperatura ambiental pero también del
aumento de la temperatura en el mar lo
que propicia una mayor intensidad de los
huracanes y que haya más huracanes de
por sí sobre todo en la zona del caribe
hablamos también de la deforestación de
la selva amazónica que puede llegar
próximamente a un punto de no retorno en
que se alteraría de forma irreversible
el ecosistema y la función que tiene en
la amazonía para todo en nuestro planeta
también hablamos de las mega sequías del
sur y es que en el centro de chile se
habla de que se registraron la sequía
más larga en los últimos 1.000 años que
ya dura más de 13 años no la sequía más
larga y más grave por otro lado el
deshielo de los glaciares de los andes
tropicales y es que desde
1980 ya han perdido el 30 por ciento de
su superficie con la consiguiente
pérdida también han de aguadulce
hablamos también de la reducción de las
cosechas que genera más inseguridad
alimentaria un problema que ya
atraviesan en muchas partes de la región
por otro lado el informe señala otra
cuestión a masa de preparación y es que
dice que es necesario establecer una
mayor cooperación entre agencias locales
regionales e internacionales para poder
predecir el clima tropical y los eventos
meteorológicos extremos para que no
tengan efectos tan negativos digamos
sobre las poblaciones y el medio
ambiente y américa del sur es la región
con más deficiencias en sistema de
alerta temprana y por último recordar
que un tercio de la población
latinoamericana es pobre por lo que la
población pobre está más expuesta tanto
por en relación con el sustento
económico como en sus residencias más
expuestos al cambio climático lo que
impide también digamos avanzar en la
reducción de las desigualdades en la
región rosa y lo que vemos cada vez al
pasar los años y también casi que los
días es realmente devastador y realmente
preocupante los expertos que hemos
consultado aquí bastantes veces en
nuestro espacio de directo américa del
invitado del día dicen que todavía
digamos hay un margen para actuar pero
al final no terminamos viendo de
acciones concretas de los gobiernos
incluso hasta de nosotros mismos no rosa
no por supuesto y lo que hemos comentado
en múltiples ocasiones como precisamente
la guerra en ucrania la reacción que
está teniendo rusia no de digamos a
reducir la energía que exporta hacia la
unión europea está poniendo en evidencia
una necesidad de hidrocarburos a corto
plazo que va completamente en
contradicción con la reducción de estas
digamos a materias primas como fuente de
energía para realmente poder sobrellevar
o limitar los efectos del cambio
climático no raúl claro rosa y bueno
cerramos entonces en nuestra sección de
revistas de prensa con el socavón que se
abrió en tierra amarilla en atacama
chile vamos a verlo en la tercera y bío
bío chile exactamente y sólo pues para
actualizar un poco cuál es la situación
porque ya la comentamos aquí
extensamente dedicamos toda una sección
a este socavón y a la reacción de la
población pero ahora en todo caso las
autoridades chilenas afirman que hay
información suficiente para concluir que
la minera realizó una sobreexplotación
de la zona recordemos que este socavón
se abrió en tierra amarilla en una
población de unos 20 mil habitantes en
chile en la región de atacama
fue eso al lado de una mina explotada
por una minera internacional que
pertenece a un grupo canadiense con
participación japonesa también la
minería candelaria raúl